[Music]
for better to come good must stand aside
the most terrifying thing is to accept
oneself completely
[Music]
thinking is difficult that is why most
people judge
shame is a soul eating emotions
[Music]
what you resist persists
[Music]
words are animals alive with the will of
their own
we cannot change anything unless we
accept it
[Music]
the true leader is always led
there is no coming to conscious without
pain
i do not aspire to be a good man i
aspire to be a whole man
show me a sane man and i'll cure him for
you
you are what you do not what you say you
will do
[Music]
the privilege of a lifetime is to become
who you truly are
[Music]
i'm not what i happen to be and what i
choose to become
where wisdom reigns there is no conflict
between thinking and feeling
the gods have become our diseases
explore daily the will of god
in each of us there is another whom we
do not know
if one does not understand a person one
tends to regard him as a fool
children are educated by what the
grown-up is and not by his talk
i shall not commit the fashionable
stupidity of regarding everything i
cannot explain as a fraud
knowing your own darkness is the best
method for dealing with the darkness of
other people
whatever is rejected from the self
appears in the world as an event
wholeness is not achieved by cutting off
a portion of one's being but by
integration of the countries
[Music]
your visions will become clear only when
you can look into your own heart who
looks outside dreams who looks inside
awakes
[Music]
everything that irritates us about
others can lead us to an understanding
of ourselves
[Music]
nervous is always a substitute for
legitimate suffering
[Music]
the reason of evil in the world is that
people are not able to tell their
stories
until you make the unconscious conscious
it will direct your life and you'll call
it faith
[Music]
the healthy man doesn't torture others
generally it is a tortured who turn into
turtles
follow that wheel and that way which
experience confirms to be your own
nothing has a stronger influence
psychologically on their environment and
especially on their children than the
unlived life of the parent
[Music]
mid-life is a time to let go of an
over-dominant echo and to contemplate
the deeper significance of human
existence
[Music]
intuition does not denote something
contrary to reason but something outside
of the province of reason
[Music]
the shoes that fits one person pinches
another there is no recipe for living
that use all cases
[Music]
faith hope love and insight are the
highest achievements of human effort
they are found given by experience
the craziest tragedy of the family is
the lived life of the parent
where love rules there is no will to
power and where power predominance love
is lacking the one is the shadow of the
other
the first half of life is devoted to
forming a healthy ego the second half is
going inward and letting go of it
[Music]
the meeting of two personalities is like
the contact of two chemical substances
if there is any reaction both are
transformed
[Music]
the best political social and spiritual
work we can do is to withdraw the
projection of our shadow onto others
the majority of my patients consisted
not of believers but of those who had
lost their faith
[Music]
if the path before you is clear you are
probably on someone else's
nobody as long as he moves him all the
chaotic corners of life is without
trouble
[Music]
every human life contains a potential if
their potential is not fulfilled then
the life was wasted
the bigger the crowd the more negligible
the individual
[Music]
people will do anything no matter how
absurd to avoid facing their own souls
[Music]
a creative person has little power over
his life he is not free he is captive
and driven by his own diamond
my whole being was seeking for something
still unknown which might control
meaning upon the banality of life
sometimes you have to do something
unforgivable just to be able to go on
living
[Music]
in all cases there is a cosmos in all
disorder a secret order
as far as we can discern the sole
purpose of human existence is to kindle
a light of meaning in the darkness of
mere being
[Music]
the pendulum of the mind oscillates
between sense and nonsense not between
right or wrong
[Music]
we meet ourselves time and again in a
thousand disguises of the path of life
[Music]
how can i be substantial if i do not
cast a shadow i must have a dark side
also if i am to be a hole
no tree it is said can grow to heaven
unless its roots reach down to hell
[Music]
without this playing fantasy no creative
work has ever yet come traverse
the depth we order the play of the
imagination is incalculable
[Music]
sensation tells us a thing is
thinking tells us what it is think is
feeling tells us what this thing is to
us
[Music]
there can be no transforming of darkness
into light and of epicenter movement
without emotion
one doesn't become enlightened by
imagining figures of light but by making
the darkness conscious
[Music]
[Music]
you